Hi, what you up to? Putting together
a Bake Off playlist. Check this out.
Scone Jovi, Bun Direction,
Lethal Drizzle, Flan Duran.
So, what, sorry,
have you put together a whole
playlist of baking puns? Yeah.
Susie Choux, Naan Inch Nails,
Crusty Springfield.
No, Noel, we promised each other
we wouldn't do puns.
I know but Ganaches To Ashes,
Dough-ana Ross.
Stop, Noel, stop, no, honestly,
let me start the show.
Welcome to
The Great British Bake Off.
Fiddler On The Proof, Whisk And
Shout, Total Eclipse Of The Tart.
Come and lie down. Ringo Star Anise.
Come and lie down here.
Bun DMC, Quiche Richards.
Can I get a medic please?
Sitting On The Dock Of The Bagel,
Take Another Little Pizza My Heart!
Argh.
Last time...
Where's my proving bag?
Is this it?
As bread rose...
Ugh. ..so did the pressure.
Breathe.
While Michael's clever campfire
won him Star Baker...
Michael.
..it was Amelia who failed
to make the cut.
It does look a bit clumsy.
I'm so sorry.
Now... Ulgh.
..Bake Off's first ever dairy week.
There's no point crying over
spilt milk, is there?
This baking staple will be
pushed to its limit...
Uh, no, no, no, no.
Disaster.
..in cakes, tarts, and the most
stunning milk sweets
ever to grace the tent.
That's melted.
You'd eat it if you were given it.
As a prisoner maybe.
As a prisoner... maybe.
I'm still here.
What? So, yeah, I'm just happy.
It feels like home now,
my voice is back,
so be very afraid, Mr Hollywood.
Um, I can probably call him
Pablo, now it's week four.
Bing.
Bread week went surprisingly well,
but dairy's different from bread,
isn't it? Could ruin it.
I'm apprehensive cos
I don't do a lot of dairy work.
I didn't realise that
dairy is not only a cow,
there's like goat,
sheep, buffalo, horse?
Could go vegan this week just
based on the whole dairy situation.
Morning, bakers. Today we're
going to do something we have never
done before on Bake Off, we're
going to celebrate all things dairy.
The judges would like you to
make a dairy cake.
So your cake mixture needs to
contain a cultured dairy product.
We're talking butter that's
gone to Glyndebourne.
That is the kind of thing,
or buttermilk or yoghurt, which
should make a moist sponge.
You have 2 hours and 15 minutes.
On your marks. Get set.
Bake.
God, I'm starting to tremble.
I think it's just,
I don't know, it's just me,
and it's just being in here.
I like dairy.
Dairy's good.
NOEL: The dairy world is
a hotbed of innovation.
Now artisan bakers are bucking
the plant-based trend
and harnessing the very best
it has to offer.
I'm just going to add yoghurt.
Well, it's dairy week, isn't it?
So...
..just got to get it all in there.
And with its creamy decadence
and microbial benefits,
cultured dairy is fast becoming
a darling of cake baking.
This week, we want them
really to celebrate dairy.
Now, more to the point, we want them
to bring in a cultured milk,
buttermilk, a yoghurt.
They can be used to
help moisten a cake,
and it's quite common
in northern Europe,
Germany, and Scandinavian
countries, to do that.
Where they've gotta be careful
is, by adding cultures,
they may overbake it.
It'll dry the cake out, and it'll
almost be like cardboard inside.
Hello. Good morning, Steph.
Right, Steph, tell us
all about your dairy cake.
So this is my answer
to everything dairy cake,
so it's chocolate and raspberry.
If you're happy, it's a good cake.
If you're sad, it's a good cake.
What's the cultured dairy product?
Uh, so it's buttermilk.
Steph's chocolate and
raspberry buttermilk cake
will be topped with a chocolate
drizzle, raspberry coulis,
and crushed pistachios.
What do you think buttermilk
does to your cake?
Moist and light, light.
So a little bit of like
a spongey texture. What, why?
Um...
I don't know. Lactic acid.
Do you know? My mum said,
"Do you know why? It's cos
it's got lactic acid in it."
I thought, "Oh, shut up, Mum."
Steph's not the only baker
doubting their dairy cake know-how.
I think it's like old milk,
so the acid in that helps it
do things, yeah.
It has to ferment with
the baking powder maybe?
And a few bits and pieces,
so it sort of ferments a little bit.
Yeah.
Rosie's science is in fact spot on.
And she's hoping her
cake will be as well,
with buttermilk, meringue kisses,
and a home-made limoncello.
It's like a lemon cake
but with a slightly vodka-y kick.
And she's not the only baker
who thinks a little limoncello
can go a long way.
Is that just limoncello?
It's basically just
limoncello with icing sugar, yeah.
Is that spare?
Yeah, it's definitely spare.
It's quite strong. Give it a go.
I went for a full mouthful. Wow.
That is actually quite good,
isn't it? That's not a sentence
many boys say to me.
David's limoncello glaze will
top a lemon and poppy seed cake
and, for his cultured dairy,
he's opted for yoghurt.
I just really like yoghurt.
Yoghurt still keeps a creaminess.
I love the tanginess, and I love all
the cultures cos it's good for you,
it's good for the microbiome.
And yoghurt is proving
a popular choice.
Although not always with
the microbiome in mind.
It's a thick and creamy
natural yoghurt,
and, uh, yeah, no half measures
on here. It's full fat all the way.
Phil's yoghurt cake will be
subtlety flavoured with rose water
and adorned with
delicate piped roses,
proving even truck drivers can get
in touch with their feminine side.
What do you drive about
when you're driving your lorry?
Uh, a fuel tanker.
44-tonne fuel tanker.
Really? Yeah.
You got one of them...
IMITATES TRUCK HORN
Oh, yeah, it's... Have you?
..purrp-purrp.
Does it feel powerful? Yeah, oh,
yeah, yeah. King of the road.
You ever run anyone over?
I've done a few pigeons.
Done a few...
THEY LAUGH
Yeah.
Wow.
I'm making a banana chocolate cake,
with some natural set yoghurt in it.
So it's in a nice tin.
I suppose this is like
a glammed-up version of my humble
banana loaf
that I usually make at home.
Priya's pimped up banana
and chocolate yoghurt cake will be
topped with a toffee sauce
and dried bananas.
Have you got all the flour in there?
Yes. Looks quite split.
It will, yeah, yeah, well, yeah, it
does that, but it's the yoghurt.
The bananas are quite mushy as well.
It'll be all right. Thank you very
much. No pressure. Thank you.
He is literally banana boy.
No. He loves bananas.
When it comes to a dairy cake,
managing moisture is crucial.
Malt extract.
Just a little bit. Ta-da.
Add too much, and it could be left
fragile and prone to tearing.
This should be fine.
It's still thick.
But one baker is throwing
caution to the wind,
with two types of cultured dairy.
So I'm using sour cream
and, if that wasn't enough dairy,
I'm going to make a cheesecake swirl
because my cake's quite soft.
That's like a weak spot,
so it can tear at the weak spot.
Can. Hopefully won't.
Michael's hoping his delicate
raspberry cheesecake swirl
will perfectly enhance
his sour lemon cake.
I'm feeling anxious.
I made this cake
ten times this week.
W-wow. You must have
very fat friends.
It's all gone in the bin cos it
didn't work. It only worked once.
Come on, bakers, a bit of cheering.
Yay!
Round of applause for
half an hour through the bake.
Everyone's like, "I'm not cheering."
Nobody listening.
Bakers, I've just spoken to Paul,
he's getting rid of
nine of you this week.
You heard that, didn't you?
OK, we'll go into the oven.
It's on 170.
I will check it at 40 minutes.
40 minutes I'm popping
it in the oven for now.
In practice, it's torn,
it's been underbaked,
it's been overbaked, it's sunk.
So we're just going to have to cross
our fingers and pray to the heavens.
Michael might be fretting
about his double-dairy gamble...
..but those with a less complex bake
can't relax just yet either.
There is a small
matter of decoration.
So, I am making buttercream flowers.
You know, I want to
introduce cute things.
Helena's using her flowers
to embellish an almond and
buttermilk cake
but, true to form, her theme
is less than conventional.
I'm decorating it as a little
ghost, which is what I...
Of course. Yeah. Yes!
It's a cute ghost though. Excuse me,
I have to see what's there.
Oh, it's a little vampire.
Prue, just wait.
Ah!
Look forward to it. Thanks.
Thank you.
I don't know what to say.
I love you.
Well, I've told my husband
I'm divorcing him
so we can marry on Halloween.
I'll tell Birdy today.
Yeah, you tell her.
So I'm making petals and leaves,
decorated in white chocolate,
so more dairy.
They're going to go
on top of my cake.
Beneath her biscuit leaves,
Alice's yoghurt cake
will be flavoured with
cardamom and pistachio.
I actually took some in for
the kids this week cos like,
"Yeah, I just made this, try this."
They were like, "What is it?"
Um, it was like, "It's OK, but it's
not like anything we've had before."
Pistachio and cardamom, it's quite
an interesting combination
but, you know, you've gotta kind
of try out some different things.
And when it comes to decoration,
one baker is determined to
try out everything.
I have got pecan crumble,
and then I've got rhubarb
flavoured meringue kisses,
and I've got apple crisps, and I've
got freeze-dried raspberries.
Michelle's highly finished
buttermilk cake will be
flavoured with rhubarb and apples,
and topped with
a custard buttercream,
evoking memories of her childhood.
When I was young,
I was to stand there,
stirring the milk for my mum, and
then we just add it to it and boil.
II love, I love the custard powder.
While Michelle is
harnessing home comforts,
Henry is looking further afield.
I've been to Germany
a fair few times.
Streusel cake brings back lovely
memories of breakfast in Germany.
It does, it does.
Henry's ode to a German breakfast
is a spiced apple yoghurt cake
topped with apple crisps
and a cinnamon streusel.
Here we've got streusel topping.
Might put a bit more water in this,
actually. How much?
Uh... I can't even work
a simple tap. That's perfect, Noel.
That's enough, is it?
That's brilliant, thank you, dear.
There you go, see that?
That's how I got this job.
They knew.
Bakers, you have 45 minutes left!
For dairy dallying!
I'm just so tight with time.
My timer says two minutes,
but my brain says now.
I'm going in.
Ooh.
The extra rise from the cultured
dairy means the bakers have
taken advantage of large
elaborate tins.
It will release from the pan,
I hope.
But the more detailed the tin,
the harder it is to unmould.
I'm just worried it's not
going to come out.
You got this, you got this,
you're a really good baker.
It feels stuck.
Where? Not this side.
Ooh.
I...
..I broke the stand.
HE GASPS
Don't worry about it.
I'll find another stand.
I broke a stand. It's gonna sink,
it's going to sink,
it's going to sink.
Tsh, tsh, tsh, tsh, tsh.
There you go.
Oh, my God, I'm so sorry,
I broke it.
I'll hold it, sorry, Phil.
You sure? Thank you.
I broke the... I broke the stand.
That's fine. The cake looks great.
Ooh, come on.
Yay.
Oh...
Oh, no.
This normally comes out
easier than this.
Woo!
What a relief.
Uh-oh. No, it's coming, yeah. Yay!
As the relief
spreads across the tent...
It's always good
when it comes out the tin.
It's happening.
It's time for Michael to see
if his gamble has paid off.
Movement.
It's not coming,
it's not coming. No.
I'd run a knife round
the middle, you know.
Oh, for goodness' sake.
Uh. No.
It's coming, it's coming.
Oh, no!
No, no, no, no.
It's cracked.
It's caught right down the middle.
Pretty much my worst nightmare.
It's un-rescuable.
Bakers! 15 minutes left!
Haven't got time.
I have to, ugh.
Are you all right?
Oh, my God, my heart's pounding.
This is like the glaze to
kind of soak into the cake.
Buttermilk icing.
Chuck all the decoration on it.
Look, this is lifting out. Ugh.
There you go. Pfft.
I'm going to name her Hazel.
That is our baby.
Let's have
many, many, many children.
Groovy Ghoulies.
Oh, come on.
I'm so nervous. OK.
Think tranquil thoughts.
Feeling quite deflated.
Surely you've got a bit of leeway,
cos you're Star Baker.
Not any more.
Wow.
Uh, stop shaking.
God...
Shaky hands.
Stressy stress, stress.
Uh...
Don't panic.
Bakers, your time is up.
SHE SIGHS
Look at it.
Look at that.
If it was at home, I'd put
it in the bin, and that's a shame.
Well done. Well done, well done.
Yeah, don't be nice to me
yet, please. OK.
Won't be nice to you.
I like your T-shirt.
Now the bakers' dairy cakes will
face the judgment of Paul and Prue.
Hello, Henry. Hello, you OK?
Hello.
The definition is fantastic.
You know, the blades
that are sticking out.
I think it looks great.
OK, let's have a look inside.
The dairy I've used is a yoghurt.
It's very delicious.
It's a very nice, light cake,
and that's the whole test.
I love the nuts in there
and the apple in there
because they actually blend
beautifully well together.
It's a really good cake.
Thank you very much, thank you.
Yeah.
What's the alcohol level in there?
Uh, it's... High.
It's just vodka with
some home-made limoncello.
Perfect for Prue.
The use of the cultured milk,
spot on.
Thank you. The sponge
is light, it's airy.
That lemon comes through.
Rosie, that is beautiful.
Thank you, darling.
That's the right place for it.
Thank you very much, Rosie.
Yes, it's both
scary and sweet.
It's got a lovely, structure,
lovely colour.
It's good.
For a mad woman, you're doing well.
Pot, kettle.
It's very neat.
Beautiful.
Can't wait to taste it.
The structure inside
is nice and light.
The lemon comes through.
Poppy's one of my favourite
things to bake with,
I think it's fantastic.
I love it.
I really do.
So much chocolate.
But that is the answer to
everything, isn't it?
That is the answer to everything.
And buttermilk is
the dairy in there.
It's a lovely, light, moist sponge,
this is how it should be.
It is so rich.
A little bit will go a long way.
Well done, thank you.
Well done, Steph.
The decoration's
a little disappointing.
It's just a bit messy.
OK.
Texture's pretty good actually.
I'm not getting a lot of rose.
You could've dialled that up
a little bit more.
Mm-hm. Thank you.
Well, Alice, I have to tell you that
I think it looks really, really
pretty. Let's have a look.
The cake is a little... bland.
Where's the lemon drizzle? Where's
the cardamom? Where's the pistachio?
But, actually the texture's good.
It's light, it's moist.
Thank you very much indeed.
Thank you.
Decoration is good.
Yeah, very good.
I'll hold judgment on
what the texture's like.
Hmm, that is a lot of chocolate,
and that outside is really tough.
Mmm-hmm.
But, your banana bread is
beautiful, actually.
It's got such a lightness to it.
Thank you, Priya.
SHE MOUTHS
The little meringues
look really beautiful.
OK, let's have a look inside.
It's not as loose and open
as I expected it to be. OK.
Could be the liquid from the rhubarb
that's dripping in there.
In the middle, it's claggy.
Is there a Welsh word for claggy?
I think it's claggy. You think
it's claggy, the Welsh word?
Hiya.
Hi, Michael.
Right. Yeah...
You'd better tell us all about it.
The sticking problem.
Well, you've lost
the definition. Yeah.
It droops, half of it's missing,
it's cracked down the middle,
the icing looks terrible.
OK, let's have a look inside.
That is delicious.
Very clever with the raspberry
cheesecake folding through it.
Tastes great, looks a mess.
OK, yeah.
Thank you.
SHE WHISPERS: You did good.
Stand out. You did good.
Oh...
Can it go in the bin now?
For subtitling services, contatct:
waqas.zahoor89@gmail.com
Sometimes it works,
sometimes it doesn't.
It's just a cake.
I know it's just a cake.
Can I jump in the river now?
Tough, brutal.
Finished it with seconds
to spare, really.
That went well. That's the best
signature I've had, actually.
Mind you, that's not saying... that's
not saying much, but, it was good.
Dairy week isn't about to
get any easier.
The bakers have no idea
what they'll face next.
Right, my lovely bakers,
time for your Technical Challenge,
which today has been
set for you by Prue.
All the elements
are equally important.
So don't mess up on any of them.
Right, so no pressure.
Bye-bye.
Off you pop, kids.
What are they up to today?
Car-boot sale.
Oh, they're selling off
some of Paul's car boots.
Exactly.
Today for your Technical Challenge,
Prue would like to transport you
back to the Tudor times.
But this particular recipe
Henry VIII liked it so much
he's said to have kept
it under lock and key.
Prue would like you to
make 12 maids of honour.
They must have a flaky
rough puff pastry case,
one layer of lemon curd,
a silky smooth, well-risen,
cheese curd filling
topped with a Tudor rose.
That was like watching you
give birth there.
Uh, you've got two hours.
Which is slightly less
than you need to say it.
On your marks.
Get set.
Bake.
THUD
Sorry.
What is a maid of honour?
Baking curd cheese?
Doesn't sound very pleasant.
But the curdled dairy is
just the start.
I haven't made lemon curd before.
Haven't made a rough puff before.
Help.
Curd tarts then.
They're called maids of honour,
Richmond maids of honour.
There's the rough puff pastry
and lemon curd in the bottom,
and then a curd cheese.
Then they have to make a stencil
to get a perfect Tudor rose.
You're challenging the
bakers on making the curd
but also the pastry,
which can be tricky.
I want to see the layers of pastry.
Mm-hm.
And you do need to bake it blind.
Or you get a soggy bottom.
Exactly, Paul!
I don't want to eat too many
cos I know I've got ten to try.
But I'm going to eat this one, I
can't help it. This is good though.
Right.
Trying to accept things
for what they are today
and have fun regardless.
Make a pastry dough
using the cubed butter.
OK, that's fine.
I'm adding some water to it,
an ill-defined amount of water.
Oh, come on.
Then you're meant to roll that.
Take over for me.
I am just so hot just rolling.
There you go. Oh, thanks.
Uh, that was, that was great.
You're going to be fine now. I can
tell you don't go to the gym either.
Whoa!
Well, that was, that was...
Whoa. That was a measly roll.
God, I can't even...
I went to the gym once, I hated it.
Yeah, so did I.
Add half the frozen butter,
fold and turn, repeat and chill.
Rough puff, layers of butter
throughout the pastry
and you get these lovely
laminated layers.
So turning it and then rolling it.
As many layers as you can get
your hands on.
Oh, no.
It's just breaking.
What is wrong with my pastry?
I just add a bit more flour,
that's what I need to do.
So I'm putting this into the freezer
as quickly as I can
to try and keep it cold.
I need some clingfilm.
There you go.
That didn't work out for me.
OK, I'm going to go, see you later.
Hey, lovely. Have you ever had
a maids of honour?
No, have you? Yes.
Oh, when you got married?
When I got married obviously, yes.
Yeah. But to eat, no.
Right, to make the curd cheese, pour
the milk and stir in the vinegar,
until all the curds
separate from the whey.
Just put the white wine vinegar
in there to make the curds.
Get the curds, the milk solid,
and we just want these solids.
Yum.
Curdled cheese.
Urgh.
Sieve the mixture
and leave to drain.
It's disgusting. It's actually vile.
Urgh.
Right, make the lemon curd.
Just make the lemon curd,
just make it.
Phil? Yes, mate.
I've forgotten how to make curd.
Do you make it in the pan,
put the eggs in as well? Yeah.
I do like lemon curd.
But when you realise that it is just
eggs, butter, and sugar basically.
It sort of demystifies it,
you lose the magic a little bit.
Yeah. It's like when
I knew what ganache was.
Someone went, "It's just chocolate
and cream," and I went, "Oh." Yeah.
I'm trying to decide
when to stop doing the curd.
I think it thickens
more as it cools down.
That's just the lemon curd.
I'm just going to leave that now
and let it do its thing.
SANDI: While most leave
their curd to thicken
and press on with the bake...
OK.
..Priya is not finished
with hers just yet,
and is keeping it on the heat.
I know I need to get thicker.
I don't know whether it will
get any thicker if it cools,
so I'm trying this.
I can't work any quicker,
because if I mess up
then it's going to cost me.
Bakers, you have one hour. One hour.
Are you serious?
Some people are, like,
going back to pastry.
I'm like miles away from
it at the moment.
The pastry looks a mess.
It's just... What's wrong with it?
Roll the pastry and cut 12 rounds.
I'm wondering what size to go with.
That's definitely too big. Oh, God.
Hmm.
Don't make 'em too, you know...
That was it, that's all I've got. I
started a sentence I didn't finish.
If only you'd told me that at
the start. Sorry. No need to panic.
They're a bit wee.
So that's a lot of
excess pastry. Oh...
This is taking me ages
to do these pastries.
It's so hard but, uh, oh, God.
Oh, no.
I forgot to put water in it.
I mean, it's insane.
There's nothing I can do
about this now. What an idiot.
Blind bake.
You have to pre-bake the base.
I'd normally blind
bake for about 15.
Oh.
Blooming heck, everybody else
is already baking pastry.
But, yeah, my curd is set.
There you go.
I should've been doing lots of
other things at the same time.
Just half an hour remains.
Oh, that's my pastry.
That's not even going.
That's inside your,
that noise is inside your head.
See ya. It is.
While most of the bakers'
pastry is out of the oven...
Disaster.
They're looking a bit like
shortcrust.
I wonder why.
..Priya's has only just
left the fridge.
It's horrendous.
I rolled it so thin,
it's like sticking.
Look at it, it's horrendous.
Absolutely horrendous.
What shall I do?
Oh, come on.
Place the lemon curd at
the bottom of each pastry case.
Quick.
OK. They're just going in.
Add the cheese curd along with
the remaining filling ingredients.
Eggs, sugar.
Oh...
They're very small.
Not fit for a King Henry VIII,
that's for sure.
Curd cheese.
Oh, my God.
I think I'm going to do
ten minutes.
We're going to put that
in till God knows when.
Michael, could be worse,
you could've not even put
yours in the oven yet.
Ooh, mate. You could still be
cutting yours out.
Create a Tudor rose stencil.
Tudor rose.
My art teacher would be ashamed.
What the heck does an English rose
look like? I'm Welsh.
Done.
There's no Tudor rose?
You're kidding me.
Mine is blind baking. You know what
you were doing half an hour ago?
How aren't you crying?
Because we've got no time.
I literally don't understand.
I haven't got time to cry. How
long's left? Five minutes! Ooh, oh.
That is done.
So, just out the oven.
Oof, mine are boiling.
Got lentils in my soggy pastry.
These can't get any worse.
My gut feel is saying
I'm not going to be first
but, uh, who knows?
Ugh.
This one broke.
We've gotta whack
the stencil thing on.
How'd I do that?
There we go.
Time is ticking.
Absolute catastrophe.
Bakers. Your time is up.
Oh!
Oh...
Please place your bakes on
the table behind your photograph.
Got to bring it down.
Ooh, oh, oh.
Is there really any point?
Prue and Paul are expecting
ten maids of honour,
brimming with sumptuous curds,
and large enough to satisfy the
insatiable appetite of Henry VIII.
Mmm.
Right.
By and large, they're all or
almost all a little too shallow.
They're awful.
They're really bad.
Right, uh...
At least they're neat.
Yeah, they're neat.
And there is a form of something in
the middle, but they're too shallow.
They are baked through.
Moving on, quite a thin pastry,
which is good.
But there's no height there again.
Nice flavour.
Lemon curd's pretty good. OK.
These are flat as pancakes.
Probably slightly more lemon curd
than there is, uh, cheese curd.
That's a lemon curd tartlet.
What?
Not even going to look at that one.
Right, this one.
Quite a nice curd, it looks like.
There's no height,
but at least there's an
effort to put more mix in.
The taste of that one's OK.
This looks like a shortcrust pastry
not a rough puff pastry.
You can't even pick them up.
That's really lovely.
That's a new invention.
Don't encourage them, Prue.
Don't encourage them.
Shall we try one of these? Mmm, no
Tudor rose on the top of that one.
And too dry.
Not enough filling.
This one looks much nicer.
At least there's some sort of nod
to a pattern on the top. Yeah.
It is flaky. Mmm, OK.
Baked all the way through.
Shallow again.
Tastes lovely,
quite good layers of pastry.
Moving on. The pastry has shrunk.
Yeah, I mean
look at the size of that.
Quite dry again. It's overdone.
You can see where it's been boiled.
Prue and Paul will now rank
the bakers from worst to best.
In last place, surprisingly, uh,
whose is this?
What is that? I know.
I spent too long trying to
get the curd right and I just,
I never had time.
Never got anything right.
Ninth place is this one.
Who's that? Me.
Do you know, Helena,
it was just not on brief at all?
Alice is eighth,
Michael's seventh,
Phil's sixth,
Michelle fifth,
Rosie's fourth,
and Henry is third.
In second spot are...
..these.
Whose are these?
Don't smile.
At least it was an attempt
of a Tudor rose on the top.
And so that leaves this one.
Who's that?
Steph, I wish I could
say they were the best
maids of honour I've ever eaten.
Sorry. But they were certainly
the best of this lot.
Well done.
I came out quite unscathed.
It's a plus, it's a big plus.
He put us all on the naughty step
so, uh, yeah.
Must do better tomorrow.
I messed up on the pastry, I mean,
what the hell was I thinking?
I'm disappointed,
of course I am, but,
it's only my own fault,
it's not anyone else's.
Today's gone badly,
but I want to just enjoy
the Showstopper
because if I go, I don't want
to go feeling like this.
One challenge remains,
one last chance for the bakers to
earn their place in the tent.
I'm going to start on a cheerful
note.
Best Technical ever.
PRUE LAUGHS
Nice cup of tea.
Steph is kind of the good news
story.
She came first in the Technical.
Who else is up there at the top?
We've got David...
Uh, David, Henry, I think, for sure.
Let's have a look at the muddy
waters down at the, er...
Everybody else. Yeah.
Michael, Priya.
Priya's was a car crash.
You're using car terminology now.
So I can compute.
So, just working it out for Paul.
I think, coming into the
Showstopper,
it's going to mean a lot.
There is a huge potential for two
people to leave.
If two did go, it may really shock
them.
Hello, bakers.
It's time for your Showstopper
challenge.
Now, today, Paul and Prue would love
you to make a stunning display
of milk-based Indian sweets, known
as mishti.
Now, your display should contain
three different types of mishti.
That's 12 portions of mishti for
each type of mishti.
I feel like we're saying mishti
quite a lot. I'm... Go with it.
Imagine this is going to be a
centrepiece for a stunning party,
or maybe a wedding, when me and
Sandi finally get married together.
Aw, getting all mishti-eyed.
Me, too.
You've got three and a half hours.
On your marks... Get set... Bake!
With Indian sweets, my comfort
zone is probably here,
but this is way back.
Everything is worrying me, at all
times.
What am I looking for? A spoon.
If it all goes badly, I'll probably
go and cry outside afterwards,
but for now I've just got to do what
I can do.
This Showstopper's going to be
fascinating.
The Indian sweets are all about
vibrancy, it's about colour.
They are used at birthdays,
weddings, predominantly,
and we want that vibrancy.
It's that sense of celebration.
It's a wonderful opportunity for the
bakers, to see if they can bring
their own imagination, their own
taste and personality,
to an Indian sweet, which is still
recognisably Indian,
in the sense that it's small,
colourful, celebratory -
a real Showstopper to look at.
Prue and Paul have asked the bakers
to make their mishti out of a sweet
base called khoya,
an ancient form of condensed milk
that dates back thousands of years.
Khoya is where you simmer the milk
down,
and you end up with milk solids.
Oh. And it does require a little
elbow grease.
Come on, I'll take over.
It smells quite nice.
I don't think I trust you to do
it for that long.
Sweet shops, they use powder milk.
Only nutters do it this way.
So, here I am.
PAUL: Good morning. Oh, yeah.
So, Alice. Indian sweets, tell us
about it.
Sure, yeah. So, I'm doing a kind
of Indian-British fusion on this,
so I'm doing an afternoon tea.
Er, so, my flavours are kind of
inspired by that.
NOEL: For her afternoon tea, Alice
will make a khoya carrot cake,
which she'll serve with coffee
and a slice of chocolate cheesecake.
Never done anything like this
before, so...
SANDI: Like, evaporated milk?
Yeah, so this is going to take,
like, two hours.
But you don't want to burn it.
Because burnt milk is the end.
And it ruins the whole thing. Yeah.
Good luck. Thank you.
Just checking it's not burning on
the bottom.
Ah. It's burnt.
But keeping a close eye on their
khoya is only half the battle.
There was a bit of burnage.
HENRY SIGHS
The bakers must also infuse it with
mouth-watering flavours.
I am making saffron and cardamom
sweets.
They're actually quite traditional,
and I love them,
they're just, like, my favourite
thing, absolute favourite.
I used to love them as a child,
and I still love them.
Priya's hoping the evocative
flavours of her childhood -
lychee, saffron and mango -
will be enough to keep her in the
competition.
I love this stuff. Like, I really
do.
It's special food, cos it's the sort
of stuff you have
if somebody had a baby, or a
wedding.
Could be a present. And, yeah, it
was quite a learning curve
to try and make this stuff at home.
And my dad was like,
"Yeah, I used to make this stuff at
home,
"I used to sit there for five hours,
"and just stir the pot when I was a
child in the village,"
and that would be his job.
I'll come back and be the child
for you, just do a bit of stirring.
Yeah, just be my dad.
PAUL: Good luck, Priya. Thank you.
Thank you.
NOEL: Priya is not the only baker
who has everything riding on their
sweets.
Oh, the pressure's on, yeah.
So I'm trying really hard.
I am making sweets based on the
Indian flag,
the colours of the Indian flag,
which are green, orange and white.
Michael's trusting his Indian flag
to hoist him out of trouble.
The orange will be represented
by mango, the green, pistachio,
and the white, with lemon and
rose-water.
All of which are an homage
to his Bengali grandfather.
Do you feel any pressure with your
heritage?
Um, I do, but then, also, I don't
like Indian milk sweets.
Any of them.
I like that you're making a
Showstopper
that you don't want to eat.
PRUE: Well, I think it sounds
wonderful.
If I get it done. Good luck,
Michael. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.
While the fight at the bottom is
well and truly on,
so too is the battle at the top.
Hopefully, I'm going to do well.
Flavour - well, we're going for some
rose and pistachio.
It'll take on a nice pink hue.
Bit of Steph personality in there,
indeed.
Steph's hoping her three mishti -
rose and pistachio, mango,
and date and walnut - will be
enough to secure Star Baker.
If you don't win Star Baker this
week... Please don't say it.
..something weird's gone wrong.
No, he's... he's...
Setting the pace. Who're you
pointing at? David. David's...
David, he's got nothing.
Look at his fringe. Nowhere.
Yeah, OK. Well, his fringe game is
poor, isn't it?
His fringe game is absolutely
ridiculous. We win on that.
I'm just putting kewra water in.
I had to ask an Indian friend how to
pronounce this.
It's from the flower of the pandan
plant, and it's very perfumy.
David's showcasing striking designs
and strong flavours -
kewra water cuboids, cardamom
spheres and carrot khoya,
served on crisp fennel tuiles.
So, it's fennel seeds.
Tell me if there's too much of that
in it.
It's not punching me, like that.
Cool, perfect.
Also, not going to - as you can
see - dive in for a second bit.
Fill you with confidence? Yes.
That's my boy!
Half an hour into the challenge...
Whoa. ..and the bakers' khoya is
still on the heat.
So, to give them a chance of getting
their sweets done,
Paul and Prue have offered a
lifeline.
They've allowed them to make one of
their batches however they choose.
So, one batch, a bit of a quick
khoya, with a condensed milk base.
So I'm cheating a wee bit.
While most are saving time,
by making their third sweet with
condensed milk...
I'm just glad to get one thing out
of the way.
..one baker has chosen something a
lot more time-consuming.
That is pistachio and raspberry
kulfi,
which is like an ice cream,
essentially.
It does have to cool, which'll take
a bit longer,
and that literally is dependent
on the freezer being cold.
Yeah, so I've just got to hope
there.
While Henry may be banking on the
cold of the chiller,
his seaside mishti should evoke
the heat of a summer day,
with orange and coconut
complementing his risky raspberry
ice cream.
Huge risk. If the ice cream doesn't
set, I'll cry.
I cry at anything.
I cry, like, at Neighbours.
Yeah, that made me cry.
When I was in that vulnerable state,
they got me to do this show.
Temporary madness.
They made me sign a load of papers.
The next thing I knew I was in a
tent.
Sandi, are you going to do the time
call, or me?
All right, I'll do it.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Oh, Jesus. No.
You're going to have to come out
of there, eventually.
You know that, don't you?
SACK THUMPS
This is worrying.
Come on.
While Henry has an anxious wait for
his ice cream to set,
the rest of the bakers can press on
with their shortcut sweets.
Done.
With over 100 different types of
mishti to choose from,
Paul and Prue are hoping to see
the wide variety
this confectionery has to offer.
Mine will be small, deep-fried,
almost like doughnuts.
Classic, when it comes to Indian
sweets.
But, true to form, Michelle is
opting for something
a little closer to home.
I am making a rice pudding.
My husband's nan, she used to make
the best rice pudding.
So this is in memory of Ben's nan.
Michelle will serve passion fruit
discs and raspberry hexagons,
alongside her tonka bean rice
pudding.
In my rice pudding, instead of
serving it in a bowl,
I just thought it'd be quite nice to
serve it in a little tart case.
And she's not the only baker giving
these eastern delicacies
a western twist.
All the Indian sweets I'm making are
based on an old British sweet shop,
so I'm making a nice chocolate
coconut bar.
Alongside her coconut chocolates,
Helena's sweet shop
will be stocked with parma violets
and lemon sherbets.
All will be served with some unique
cutlery.
So, I'm making biscuit spoons.
Biscuit spoons. Course you are.
God, I know. I know.
I knew that I'd come across you
making biscuit spoons.
Some witchy magic. Yeah.
Come on!
God, this is taking ages.
For the sweets that aren't taking
ages...
..attention can turn to decoration.
Mishti are often traditionally
served as bold centrepieces,
and one baker is really celebrating
with colour.
I am making red and yellow sweeties,
and they will be individual ones,
just with a bit of gold leaf and a
bit of rose petals,
but there'll also be some tiny
ones, as olives,
to go in the martini glasses, too.
Maybe, if I get all this done.
Rosie's hoping her fruity and floral
mishti
will evoke the elegance of a 1920s
cocktail bar.
Decorations... Sat on the side
of my martini glasses,
it'll be bloomin' colourful.
But one baker's search for
inspiration
took him no further than his
back door.
I was just standing at the
conservatory, staring into space,
thinking of ideas, and I thought,
"Oh, my garden looks a little bit
nice."
And that sort of inspired me to make
a little display.
Rockery garden with pebbles,
a chocolate soil and Norman the
Gnome.
And I thought, "Oh, I'll give him a
day out."
Nestled at the feet of Norman
will be Phil's garden of mishti.
His elderflower rockery and
pistachio roses
will be home to his blueberry
butterflies.
What's happening here? I'm making
some stones.
Stones. And this is soil? Yeah.
Is that real soil, or have you made
that?
Yeah, I dug it up from out there.
Nice.
Not bothering with the baking any
more? No, no, no.
Just going to feed Paul soil.
Come on, smash this one.
I will do. Come on, get out of my
way. All right.
45 minutes to go...
The ice cream, it hasn't set.
Come on.
..and while Henry's ice cream might
not be ready, one thing finally is.
The khoya. That is done.
But their khoya still needs to be
shaped, coated, decorated,
and turned into beautiful sweets.
Just weighing my balls.
If I get these the wrong size,
then we've got trouble.
Henry obviously thinks size matters.
Bakers!
# Half an hour left. #
Oh. I need a new bowl now as well.
This is difficult. Ooh!
While most of the bakers are on
their final batches...
That's in a coffee sugar syrup.
Coffee to my afternoon tea.
Argh. Ah, come back.
..Henry must fry...
..mould... Oh.
..and chill, juggling all three.
Right.
My ice cream aren't as hard as I'd
like them to be.
Aw, that one's burst.
Argh. My sausage!
It's just too sticky.
That's not going to work.
So, one batch, they're meant to be
the god Ganesh's favourite sweet.
Oh, I like that a god has a
favourite sweet.
It is nice, isn't it?
He didn't go for Haribo?
Michael may be crafting divine
delicacies...
Yeah, these haven't set.
..but Henry's preparing to meet his
maker.
Come on.
Wah! No, no, no.
Oh.
Henry's didn't set.
Oh, God.
Right, we'll do the best we can
with this cos it's not done.
Can I do anything?
Nope.
Didn't think this through.
Have done that. Tick.
OK, the sugar violets.
The pink sticks. It's a bit softer
than I'd like.
At least my balls are firm.
One minute. Last minute.
Argh.
Panic mode.
Michael, are you free? Yeah.
On to where?
God. Got the proper shakes.
Oh.
Panic.
Come on.
Jiggle them around a bit.
OK, something you would present at a
wedding, I guess.
Bakers, your time is up.
Well done.
I'm so nervous about that.
Brilliant.
Oh, that's really cool. That looks
really good.
Norman, the star of the show.
The bakers' mishti will now face
the judgment of Paul and Prue.
Steph, would you like to bring
up your show stopper? Yeah.
PRUE: They're very neat. They look
amazing. I love the pink.
Reminds me of a hot dog.
HE LAUGHS
I'm open to suggestions
of what they remind you of.
Pink Panther's hot dog.
Let's see what they taste like.
Rose and pistachio.
Get the middle bit as well.
Nut flavour and the rose.
A lovely combination.
Shall we try one of these?
That's very good as well.
It's a great blend between the mango
and the coconut.
You're clever with your flavours.
I think you've done well.
Thank you.
SANDI: Well done, lovely.
Very neat, very precise,
very accurate.
And I lust after this necklace.
PAUL CHUCKLES
It's very you, Prue.
So it's kewra water and pomegranate.
It melts,
releasing all the flavours.
Really good.
Quite aromatic.
And this carrot is delicious.
The flavours are interesting.
Excellent.
They look great
cos it looks like an afternoon tea.
The cheesecake is moist and creamy.
This one, that's very
pleasant as well.
It IS like a carrot cake,
but with a much thicker paste.
Thank you. Well done. Well done.
I love the look of it.
It could easily be at a wedding.
Erm, that lemon's probably
the best one for me.
The citrus flavour is strong.
Just lovely.
And the biscuit is beautiful.
That is so difficult
not to just eat it.
Thank you.
It looks very good.
The colours match up beautifully
as well.
Really delicious.
You can taste the
cardamom and saffron.
It's nicely aromatic, isn't it? It's
beautiful. The spice blend is good.
All of them are very clever.
Rosie, I think you should be proud
of yourself.
They do look nice,
they're a nice colour. Mm.
Very different to each other.
Though I don't really like
that flowerpot one down there.
That's my favourite.
Cos I love rice pudding.
I do, but that's not rice pudding.
THEY LAUGH
Oh, OK.
I think you didn't finish.
And that one looks a bit melted.
It's got a nice vanilla.
I mean, the texture's wrong cos
it's melted but, er, it tastes OK.
You'd eat it if you were given it.
As a prisoner, maybe. As a prisoner!
THEY LAUGH
Yes. Maybe.
Really stylish.
I love the fact that
they're such different shapes.
OK.
Really delicious.
The apricot goes beautifully
with the coconut, not too sweet.
These little ones -
the almond really lifts it. OK.
That lemon,
that's very good as well. Thank you.
Well done, darling.
I think it would've been good
if you could have got a bit more
colour into the actual edible things
rather than from the decoration.
They are deep-fried and soaked
in a rose and lychee syrup.
I quite like it because it is fried.
They're quite savoury.
Shall we try one of these?
It's very difficult, I think,
to get saffron right,
and that is absolutely right.
This one's... It's nice, it's got
a good mango flavour.
Very creamy.
Overall, could've introduced
a little bit more colouring.
Nevertheless, the flavours are good.
Your flavours are pretty good.
Thank you, Priya.
I heard good things.
They're really well-done.
Sorry, I was just laughing
at the gnome.
That's my dad, do you mind?! I was
going to say something, but I won't!
It's very colourful.
The rest of them are all so classy,
they couldn't do it.
It's a sort of backhanded
compliment.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'll take that.
THEY LAUGH
Try a pebble.
I wouldn't like to eat very much of
it because it tastes slightly fake.
You've really gone overboard
with your flavours, actually. Mm!
You've just hit them with extracts
and then stamped them.
And they're all pretty samey,
aren't they? Mm.
But, thank you very much, Phil.
Thank you. Thanks, Phil.
Obviously yesterday didn't go well,
but today I did it, and that was
a personal victory, I think.
I hope I've done enough.
They were really complimentary
about the flavours.
I felt proud that I'd recreated
something that I really like.
Hmm, not so hot today,
but it's not my thing.
It's like a roller-coaster,
you know?
You're on top of the coaster then
all of a sudden you drop down
and you think, "Ugh."
I loved this Showstopper.
I was amazed at the different
flavours and the enthusiasm
and the variety and the colour.
This looks fab, doesn't it?
I mean, it's just exquisite.
Star Baker potentials?
I think Steph did well.
I think David's done well.
We have our Star Baker
certainly in one of those.
Henry could not get Star Baker.
I mean, he just did
three round balls,
which was, you know,
we're always after...
They're like mutants.
But let's not dwell
on Henry's balls.
Let's have a look at who's
suddenly in trouble.
Michael, Priya, uh...
Phil.
I think Phil's dropped.
Really disappointing.
Very, very simple stuff, that. That
was, almost kindergarten Play-Doh.
Oh, OK.
Could be the week for two people?
It very much could be, yeah.
It's very, very close.
Yeah.
Well, bakers,
I now have the pleasure of telling
you who is Star Baker.
So the person who is Star Baker this
week, uh, was very close last week
to achieving the title, but this
week has absolutely nailed it.
Our Star Baker is...
..Steph!
Woo!
Well done.
Fantastic.
That means I've got the
horrible job of announcing
the baker who's
leaving us this week.
The person who's
leaving us this week is...
..Phil.
Sorry, Phil.
What the hell's that? Don't know.
Oh, Phil, pal. What the hell's that?
Oh, my God.
Dairy week.
Curse the dairy week.
Still, had a good run.
Such an amazing group of people.
Fantastic.
Absolutely loved every second of it.
What do you think you're playing at?
Yeah, it's his fault,
you know that, right?
Phil was particularly shocked, and
he had justification to be shocked
because it was that tight,
it was that close.
It was a little bit boring,
a little bit too simple.
I think he struggled
in his Showstopper,
which is why, sadly,
Phil had to leave.
Oh, Phil! Come on, everyone.
Get in, get in.
I'm through.
Oh, God, what a weekend.
It's a massive relief. I sort of
think, "Am I going to be feeling
like I'm going to be
"going home every week, for every
week that I stay in now?
"Is this, is this just how it is?"
I knew that Priya and
I were in the bottom.
I feel a bit guilty, perhaps,
for even being here next week,
but mainly thrilled for Steph
because wow.
I was so pleased for Steph.
She's a very serious baker.
Hello? Hello.
Um, OK, so, um, I just got Star
Baker.
Oh, my God, you did?
Really? Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Bloody hell, Steph.
We're in the car park.
That's just...
Mum, you're not meant to swear.
I'm not meant to swear on TV.
Oh, sorry, I'm so sorry.
I can't believe it.
You've gotta start believing in
yourself, Steph. Yeah.
I know you won't,
but it's all right.
Next time...
Whoa.
The bakers celebrate the roaring
'20s...
I'm adding the booze.
..with decadent pies...
Slide, my pretties, slide.
..choux pastry souffles...
They look like Scotch eggs.
..and towering cocktail
cakes that will leave everyone
reaching for the bottle.
SHE GASPS
Oh, no, she's dropped her tart.
Oh...
Subtitles by Red Bee Media